[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for joining us this is range
battles presented by capital one
we're here in beautiful big sky montana
look at that and uh i'm joined in the
booth with these trying how are you
doing
good my man doing good it's gonna be a
lot of fun y'all it's gonna be a lot of
fun
all right so i know a lot of you at home
hi guys
good to see you all are probably very
confused about exactly what's going on
right now so this
is ranger battles there's superstars on
the course right now and they are
warming up
for the match tom brady aaron rodgers
bryson d schambach
phil mickelson cheyenne woods tiger
woods niece
charles barkley and larry fitzgerald now
the fun game that we have here is this
is west
driving our golf cart right now and
they're warming up everyone so our goal
is to get all of them to drill west when
golf balls
while they're warming up we're going to
be giving a ton of money away to you
guys
if you can correctly guess who hits the
carts or who's going to win our little
challenges today
and also we'll be donating to uh we'll
be doing a thousand meals but we'll get
to that later
for now we're seeing chuck warm up right
now we're seeing cheyenne and we're
seeing fits warm up you can see them
from left to right
see the clips of charles barkley golfing
before not gonna lie
it don't look that good it's so bad it's
like the best
one ever hopefully he's worked on that
swing man if not
we're gonna be coming to his head hey
you guys leave comments in the comment
section and i will be picking the
funniest ones and the best ones
read them out loud and the best comments
win some money today
well hey we got two superstar
quarterbacks on on the course right now
getting ready to warm up
that's gonna leave this uh for everyone
in the comments and for us here in the
booth which quarterback would you rather
have on your team in 2021
do you not know what happened last year
he's gonna say brady oh by the way
guys we're gonna be we're gonna be going
at this but it's a hundred dollars to
the best comment okay so don't just tell
me brady don't just tell me rogers i
want to hear exactly
why whether it's funny whether it's
serious whether you got stats
let us know why i love it but why won't
roger my why
no tom brady he's got the flow out
that's mvp
seven-time super bowl champion you know
he has more rings
by himself than the entire nfl any team
in the nfl i know
i get i i i can't bet against brady how
can you you just did
yeah okay you just come on that guy
we're starting now what happened last
year
you bet against brady i know it just
didn't go whatever hey you know what
before i get heated too
hard today as we're starting out i gotta
go down to my man in the car
west is driving the car today he's gonna
go to work how are you feeling bro you
guys are already hitting me
i'm i'm already on fire you nervous yet
yep
uh they're dude they're they're on
target today is that he looks good
kind of like sleep safe bro are you good
are you going to get a few
open spots here but i feel good i feel
safer with you guys in my ear though
that's for sure
all right well we have a challenge for
everyone who's watching right now we're
not going to start this until i announce
it
so don't drop your guesses yet so the
challenge is you can see it on your
screen there
who will hit the card first oh i already
got a danger
so yeah so drop your comments
right now let us know who you think is
going to hit the cart first
hey i got my money on cheyenne look look
already drilled
oh my god are you all right down there
oh wow you all right well should we go
first uh
should we go first let's talk about
track yeah now you got to throw some
shots at you
the king of phoenix
tell him a swing sucks phoenix you're
not in phoenix chuck
oh i got one dude they're hitting it by
the way
is cheyenne the first my money's on
cheyenne bro she might have hit she
might hit the back
we're moving my money's on cheyenne look
she's smacking her you're getting dinged
out there
so cheyenne first had uh charles had
nine tequilas on the rocks last night oh
boy
bro you might have to move closer for
charles man they're close i don't know
look
at that shot charles replay from
cheyenne smack them right in the door
hey calm down little fella
he said calm down i love it
hey everyone watching at home by the way
so wes got a megaphone and he can
communicate with those people up there
so if you have some awesome trash talk
for cheyenne larry fitz or
your kids just hit it let us know in the
comments and we'll try and get it
i don't think chuck has hit a single
ball yet these guys are
actually good
giannis
they
i hope you guys drop in the comments
that cheyenne was going to win because
if you didn't you you might have just
listened to you guys
that's actually a 200 bet right there so
if you correctly guessed who's gonna hit
the car first you can't cheat we're
watching don't worry
we're giving away 200 each
how close is he chuck that is a chip
that is what is it stratosphere what is
he aiming at
dude chuck just sent it a hard right
jesus chuck
oh my god you know his swing my knee
though
his swing looks better but i don't know
if it's getting the job done bro
[Laughter]
you know cheyenne is like 80
oh dear lord they are smacking they
are west i'll donate a thousand meals
myself if you don't flinch on the next
ball it hits you
okay okay all right you got to stay
stone cold bro okay
okay ready stone cold i'm not gonna see
it west nope
stone cold okay ready i'm not gonna move
hey
and it looks like we got our first
winners ladies and gentlemen so
these four guests that shine woods is
gonna be the first hit on the golf cart
okay crunch uh clink scale s bucks and
david a
congratulations 200 bucks just for
guessing
so i'm saying just for being here with
us if you didn't get cheyenne woods i
don't know what's wrong with you it runs
in her bloodline bro
is there any chance you can tell chuck
that you can guarantee he will not hit
you on this next one
oh it was on a line from here kind of
close i was impressed no cigar
i don't think chuck has hit him once
that counts and if i'm a gambling man i
would have guessed chuck
cheyenne's on fire dude he's like wow
scraping the ground
every time he swings maybe he's hustling
he doesn't want us to see how good he is
at golf was that chuck or cheyenne did
you guys see that
who hit who
oh
hitting moving targets too dude cheyenne
is money
shine is so hey everyone in the comments
uh
do do you over under do you think you're
better when they go or worse than
charles barkley i don't know
what's going on i would love to know
what the bleach report is very hard to
be worse than charles
i don't go off and i i think i'm better
than jordan i know see i say that and
all of a sudden i get out of there
bro but look how can how can you not do
better than me
let's see where this next ball goes he's
taking his time to see him up too
he's got like 12 balls out there oh
that's a good one chuck no
that's not should i go should i try and
drive under one for him you might have
to wait
you might have to go two yards away from
him just a joke you might have to let
him get the putter out
try to adjust bro try to adjust as he
swings oh
ladies and gentlemen right after these
three are done warming up
we're bringing out the big guns tom
brady aaron rodgers phil mickelson and
bryson d chambo are coming out
i'm excited for that and we're gonna see
out of them who can hit the card the
most so you just saw that four winners
got 200
on the last challenge this is your
chance to win some money right here who
do you think is gonna hit the cart the
most
out of those four uh and there's gonna
be six people winning
500 on this challenge yeah ring on big
bucks on this one
so it's going to be exciting so let us
know in the comments right now who do
you think's going to hit the cart the
most
six year walking with 500 bucks just for
being here with the boys
struggling you gotta love it he's oh my
god
wow she is
oh yes do you see that bro is it rolling
around another one
bro dude he is moving and she's still on
target bro
what it's in her blood bro yeah for
everyone at home that is tiger woods
she's a professional golfer if you're
wondering why
tell chuck he has to at least give us
one come on charles
this is bad luck for the phoenix suns
right now i know oh yeah the whole the
whole megaphone broke
all right he's getting oh he needs some
tips
has been pretty darn good too jesus
i actually love it though i can't
believe shy is this good at this
brian how far out should i go oh yeah go
to a hundred
oh hey man
in the comments jd maxwell said he would
rather have brady 20 21 because
he's a proven winner and a great leader
players want to play
with and yeah i don't know he's skating
out of there
jacob where are you from right from
boston that's the only way i'm believing
it
west out a 100 yards can she do it
we know what chuck's out there larry i
can't i'm losing the ball i imagine this
is the shot that chuck feels
yeah he goes out of 300 and she's
beaming him every single time i love it
oh and ladies and gentlemen don't forget
who hits the cart most out of the next
four that are coming up
six you're gonna win 500 bucks don't
forget to get your comment in before
they come out
yeah i can't see anything you guys larry
is
won the match though and he was really
good i think he's hustling
i don't know do you think charles
barkley's hustling out there he doesn't
want to point over
oh charles charles is that it is that is
that it west
no i missed it i'm losing the ball
though oh cheyenne
that had the uh that had the correct
distance we just need to move it left a
little bit
you gotta you can hit me i'm toast at
this point i just feel bad
and i want chris paul to get a ring i
don't need this bad omen in the
maybe charles needs to change his clubs
or something he's not using the right
one
that could be it oh come on larry what
is that like a seven iron or something i
don't even know
oh i don't know if you boys can see what
i'm seeing it looks like brady rogers
phil and bryson are
on their way out right now west you've
been getting beaned by just one
professional golfer you're about to have
she's got it she's got her
money bam guys we have shattered glass
we have shattered plastic no way
you're
yeah that's what i would say too if i
was playing absolutely terribly
yeah yeah i'm not trying to win i'm just
out here to have some fun
you know every time oh yeah but here's
the boys
100 yard bomb from cheyenne she's so
good
let's see what happens wait i want to
see your plexiglass break oh you're live
last year you're being dramatic
no guys it didn't shatter but there's a
crack
[Laughter]
you're pre-empting it's still broken
yeah
how are you feeling bryson d chambeau
and phil makel saying are going to
know guys i'm i'm trying to keep my cool
with that one but i don't feel too good
about it bro they're gonna if you
think you're getting smacked a lot right
now by cheyenne you're gonna have four
people
just as good as her just coming at your
head oh boy
and look at the boys
okay wow brady's kind of tall rogers
looking like me out there
yeah or the opposite actually i'm really
tall you guys
6'5 whoa wait a minute
i love it i wonder if they're drunk what
size are your pants
i think of roger's custom-made i don't
know
okay
oh that's such a flex what a flex
how are you doing okay good thanks for
watching oh the boys
do you think brady and rogers are cool
because that's what i'm saying i think
do you think they'd have beef
i wonder if they care that much they're
getting paid you know they've got
families and everything
yeah guys chuck just put his hands on
his hips
oh yeah he's he's done what does that
mean it's over four that means he's over
he's over four i don't know he's tired
dude hits he hit
one one has he he hit one it was super
challenging
there's a great challenge right there
will charles ever hit the cart find out
on the next episode
how far are you now like 75 i meant like
one i'm not like uh
i hope you got your comments in if
you're in the bleach report app right
now you better get in your comments
because six of you get 500 bucks who is
going to hit the card the most
oh bro she just knocked the flag off the
she just knocked the flag off the card i
don't think we're gonna be wow
cheyenne that's crazy she's having to
give me a reality
she's she's always here look the flag
look at the flag
oh again again bro thank god look how
skinny the flagpole
is too oh what do you think the vegas
odds were on that
we should do it does the flag get
accuracy
no west do not yes don't do it we'll die
don't do it bro
not the time we care about you we don't
want to see you die i totally appreciate
you
that's good advice hey listen
uh come on oh chuck's like man he's got
the driver out bro forget it i'm just
here you know
he's got the driver out and if he does
hit he's gonna be in trouble
now there is one twist for everyone
watching right now so
uh larry chuck and cheyenne we're kind
of just warming up so hitting as many as
they want
but we have some spawn extra special
stuff for when the four superstars get
out here
uh so the players are gonna get ten
shots each plus
one shot at the end with a golden ball
and i'll explain that a little bit later
honey ball
yeah that thing's gonna be awesome very
excited for that so we'll actually be
tallying their shots it's not just going
to be a free-for-all you're going to see
a score and there will be a winner
so six you'll get 500 as i said before
if you can correctly guess who's going
to hit the cart the most
on top of that every single ball that
hits a car this is the best part
we're donating a thousand meals to
feeding america with every thousand
meals man of charity as long as the car
gets checked
just driving as far as you can oh wow
yeah that's what i'm saying
if he shakes one you're in big trouble
because that's coming off a heater chuck
gave up
just give me one
chuck roast in the comments i just saw
the ball bounce in shag is definitely
disappointed
you know shaq's going to go on inside
inside the nba next time
this is why i have three rings and this
is why you couldn't get that golf cart
chuck what the hell was that i don't
know i don't know how many rings you
guys
say that someone correct me in the
comments oh man oh boy
this is gonna be fun oh wow wow yeah i
need you guys
chuck i need you guys as best charge
barkley roast in the comments man
we'll be original and we're gonna tell
them too we're gonna have wes the
original baby
i believe in you guys larry fitz's got a
good form too
i guess that's how i'd be doing wow he's
nice
yeah they're already certified with it
do we think do you guys know who's hit
more larry or shane probably cheyenne
[Laughter]
[Music]
chuck has pulled himself out of the
competition understandably
see chuck he gave up bro he's he's not
when's the last time he saw one
he drove it for like 300 yards he
brought the driver back out because he
was fed up with the golf cart
shenanigans yeah is chuck grabbing the
club again i think he is
oh okay oh he's back out baby he's back
out baby
back hey ladies and gentlemen i'm gonna
put 5000 meals myself
if charles barkley can hit this golf
cart it's chuck and hitler are you with
me on that back
oh tell them people are going to starve
if he doesn't hit the floor
there was the one no he's he's putting
his club away
he did his form gloves are gone oh boy
oh they're getting booted the big dogs
are coming out
all right ladies and gentlemen your
window of time to guess who's going to
hit the card most
is closing let us know in the comments
different people yeah this is the big
one right here
four people we've already given there's
already been eight hundred dollars four
people got uh 200 each for guessing that
cheyenne was going to hit
so let us know i mean the obvious guest
here i think is going to be the pro
golfers yeah
yeah i think we said but don't sleep on
that's what i'm saying don't ever count
tom brady out man
tell me what happened in his life that's
such a good question how far should west
go out on this
what are you thinking i i want to i want
to give them like a hard one
too maybe like 200 see if these golfers
are really certified like that
what do you think of what do you think
of 125 yeah i like that i like that i
like that
yeah i like that you want to dial it up
to 125. let's get it 125.
in the comments and you know golf let us
know what you think is a good distance
if they're drilling them from here
though we move them back
bro i guarantee you they're they drill
him almost every time you think
it's going to be like a meteor shower
bro
you're giving them nightmares are they
going individually and then
they're counting 10 or oh all at the
same time
wow don't worry ladies and gentlemen i
know it's going to be a little hard to
keep track of this we have a score
ticker for you we're going to be
tallying up who hits what
and uh we'll have the little instant
replay too tell them how's tom sweeney
it's game day it's so easy to spot him
too with that tv 12 hat
god i wish he wasn't so handsome i'm so
over it he went to university of
michigan
oh bro that swing is crispy i know oh of
course it is
what can't this guy do how what kind of
dances you want
can you guys tell
yeah they probably are custom oh dude
bryson's just going to
absolutely wow
geez man good luck bro i'm glad i'm
there's painters there's
paint in the bed of this in the bed of
this gator i want to see mickelson
oh man who who do you got winning bro
who's gonna hit the card
i wanna i'm pulling my curveball i'm
going aaron rodgers really yes i'm going
into the golfer
i have do we uh
let us know in the comments who is the
cart most bleach port app let's get late
aaron rodgers owns you brady oh bro
swing look pretty good too oh wow that's
on the ground
brady's seeing eli manning out there
that's why that was so bad we're getting
close
and mickelson just missed too dee shambo
looking like a strong company
one for bryson that's two hits mickelson
with the miss
rogers
um let's move in all right wes we got to
bring you in my man let's bring it up to
50. i want to see some hits
we're going to smack you bro 50 it's
over bring them up to 50. oh my gosh
oh wow uh wes dodged that one
yeah bring it up to 50 baby this is
horrifying oh man you got this you're
nervous for you bro you'll be all right
are you at 50. oh he's he's scared are
you cheaping out
bring that puppy up to 50.
yes sir the pro golfers are tied up in
one ladies and gentlemen
uh quarterbacks with a big old goose egg
are they going to hit that's what i
thought tom brady come on tom
yo yo yo yo who's that
yo
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah we have some special special rules
so don't even worry about that score too
much yet right now
zero zero three and one there is the
golden ball the golden ball
is worth triple they're gonna get one
shot each to hit the golf cart
and that's worth three and it's also
worth three times
instead of one thousand three thousand
tied up phil is lighting it up brady's
tennis ball that's looking pretty good
money too much i can't see all righty
boys that means the golden ball is
coming
out right now now i will say the big
thing about the golden ball is that
we're gonna be giving away triple
donations
because to be honest it's not possible
for brady rogers or d chambeaux to bring
it back in because mickelson is such a
sniper
did you see but here's michael's what's
that what did he say oh it's money
oh wow oh oh
mickelson
tom brady chokes under pressure
overthrows no shocks here ladies and
gentlemen overthrown
is as good as radiant rogers right now
is loving this let's see if he's got it
no
thank you you're gonna have to throw
that shot bro i didn't i
don't know that's all i know oh man we
can see it aaron
and all that's left is aaron rodgers
golden ball
huh this is a landslide victory i told
you
these three gotta have a little shout
out they're gonna keep going literally
eight to one to one to one
no i think that's it wes i think you're
all set there was that mickelson
man you must have said something to
mickelson earlier
that's the big point about the challenge
that you got on screen right now the
question was does anyone
hit the cart with their golden ball if
you said yes before mickelson started
swinging
then you would have gotten it right and
you have a chance to be one of the four
people
who wins two hundred dollars sir he
nailed it too and how old are you
bro we donated eleven hundred eleven
thousand meals eleven thousand meals
eleven thousand bills and i think i
think i want that to be a prettier
number if i can be totally honest how do
you feel about eleven thousand
do all right i i kind of don't know if
i'm allowed to do this but i think we're
just gonna
send it anyway we're sending that puppy
all the way up to fifty thousand
so we're just gonna tack on some of our
own 50 000 meals being donated and we
get to see these studs
hang out plus you guys got to hang out
with me what a landslide range battles
here i love it that's insane
did you think it was going to be this
bad no i don't think so
wes can you give us your closing regards
how was it bro
dude it was good dude those balls move
fast and phil is a man huh
is he older than tom he is right he's
about 50. tom's low 40s
it's hard to tell it's probably the
radius that's probably who motivates tom
still versus time they're on the team
together right isn't it
in brady oh yeah it's over yeah it's a
good lineup it's over
yeah it's over it's good hey you
survived plexiglas didn't get you
you're alive i'm healthy no injuries
yeah that guy's a stud
hey everybody in the comments thank our
driver this man willingly went out shout
out
shout out west manchester thanks for
watching
of course of course all right and don't
go anywhere yet ladies and gentlemen
because the whole point of doing all
these challenges and being here with us
in range battles
is we're giving away a lot of money well
that's not the whole point we're doing
donations too but we want to get
we've got the end of show winners for
all the awards that we just mentioned
and some of the challenges we just
mentioned
that's coming up soon and for now i get
to look at roger's beautiful flow
man are you aaron rodgers or tom brady
bro dude it's the flow i love him
that's the golden ball too that's the
big golden ball right there
feels money so yeah if you said yes
there'd be a golden ball hit
that's it still is money so the most
yeah he's a stunt wow that went fast huh
good enough
if you guessed that the golden ball
would hit cameron booth
that booth jet ski the kid that's
anthony lombardo 200
that's fire yeah congratulations y'all
just for hanging out and guessing
correctly
and hey even if you didn't guess
correctly you got to hang out with us
that must have been the easiest two
hundred dollars
i had to about just typing yes yo and
the mickelson won two
i feel like mickelson might have been
the favorite on most hits on the card
he's totally honest oh no question
yeah every time he swung dude i was i
was dug for nervous no question
dude so out of 10 balls he hit five and
then go to ball for three that's crazy
and then of course as we were warming up
cheyenne woods was like eighty percent
knocked off a post on the cart
of course so if you guys if you guys had
done your research
you got an easy 200 right there so yeah
look at how beautiful that looks montana
i wish we're in in the studio and out
there with the guys
it looks like a green screen bro
look it's not all golf today ladies and
gentlemen a lot of you had some
hilarious comments and we're giving away
a hundred times i want brady because
he's a six
five 245 pound monsters
72 is getting a hundred bucks for this
one right here i love that it says spark
that boy might be an msu fan
i love to hear it that's a hundred
dollars weller in spartan
in the booth we love you there oh my
goodness brady stop being so handsome
brady look at my party suit you guys
like the party suit oh yeah
we have to show them yeah well you
thought i had a suit on
where are you a clown no you get that
party suit
tom brady could never literally never
they couldn't pull it off
well ladies and gentlemen we cannot
thank you enough for joining us this has
been range battles thank you
presented by capital one we have capital
ones the match on tnt at 5 p.m
eastern it's going to be brady and phil
nicholson
versus aaron rodgers and bryson d shambo
myself and destroying signing off bro
hey man this is fun
this was fun take care y'all
[Music]
audi 5000
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]